ich gebe zu ich bin da wirklich
irgendwie enttäuscht weil wie gesagt es
hätte schon mal eine chance gegeben auch
aus parteitaktischen gründen hat man
dann diese frage aber gemacht noch
mehrere das verfahren war parteitaktik
das und dann ich sag jetzt sich das
endgültige abstimmungsverhalten war
parteitaktik der ampel
da hab ich jetzt will ich gar nicht mal
so vor waffen aber dann kriegt man es
nicht zustande und was ist dann das
ergebnis wir haben im plenum nur gehört
die union die schuld wissen sie wenn die
fdp oder viele das recht haben zu sagen
wir halten es für verfassungswidrig
stimmen nicht zu dann hat auch die union
das recht sagen dosen fdp hat die fdp
die fdp fiele fdp sagen das können
der fdp
hat schon mit
verantwortungsbewusstsein zeigen dass
der märz sagte schadenfreudig wenn er
keine mal gehör verschaffen und das ist
die regierung
ich war schon sehr sehr schade dass die
union nicht an den erträgen beteiligt er
sich an dem prozess beteiligen können
und herwig decker und zwei weitere
kollegen aus der union haben ja auch für
den regierung oder den entwurf der
gruppe wie sie gestimmt aber ich kann
ihnen sagen das hat sich geändert am
anfang gab es streit die hälfte wollte
keine impfpflicht in der union die
andere war dafür
von geändert als sie haben es eigentlich
genau richtig gesehen weil es nicht
geeignet ist und auch nicht erforderlich
gibt mildere mittel die masken pflicht
hochwirksame 42 ist ein milderes mittel
dann wir haben die situation per mikro
wirklich dass wir keine überlastung der
kliniken haben jetzt kommt das argument
es gibt geimpftes personal inzwischen
die auch krank werden durch omikron und
deshalb haben wir aktuell zum teil in
einigen kliniken ein problem wieder aber
die sind geimpft das heißt wenn ich alle
im warum die geimpften gebe es auch
weiter das ist die besonderheit beim
sterben täglich über 200 menschen ja
aber was haben ja wir haben omikron ist
im moment ungefähr vergleichbar wie eine
normale grippe lieber vor drei jahren
auch hatten dem originell lockt aber die
todeszahlen sind ungefähr so und ich
muss jetzt mal ehrlich sagen wir können
nicht die die jetzt ungeimpft sind die
haben eigenverantwortlich und so zu lang
aber dick sind geben es trotzdem weiter
sie müssen trotzdem nicht zwischen
läutet mit meinem mann möchte noch mal
alle aspekte einbringen wir haben ja
fast kein land in europa neben pflicht
gibt ja ich habe auch gegen die
impfpflicht heute gestimmt dass ich habe
keinen antrag befürwortet weil ich
keinen antrag als geeignet erachtet habe
dass er das problem löst in der form
dass auch umsetzbar ist und erst gegen
ende des kampfes gestellt habe ich mich
so nicht habe ich nein ich habe mich
nicht gegen meinen bundeskanzler
gestellt ich habe dem antrag der
hofwiese behrens nicht zugestimmt ja ich
hätte dem antrag der von professor
mühlmann zugestimmt den zehn per gericht
den mechanismus trotz aller schwächen im
antrag noch am überzeugendsten fand den
gab es nicht mehr seit gestern und darum
habe ich dann keinen antrag zugestimmt
und der bundeskanzler hatte dabei
diskutiert das mit an eine persönliche
auffassung und mache das nicht als
bundeskanzler also hier zwei dinge
gelernt das ist das richtige mittel ist
corona sache zu bekämpfen die maske dann
trage ich im ernst warum sie in der
ganzen regierung seit alle möglichen von
ausgangssperren bis zu kontakt verboten
gemacht haben wenn es eigentlich doch
nur auf die maske ankommt der leyen
deinlein die magath vielleicht neue
sperren an aber wir hatten ist nun
also weiter eine chance wenn wir
wirklich sagen endlich gibt's nur noch
dann wenn ich damit das virus ausrottet
dann werden wir nie weiterkommen es ist
ein fortschritt wenn ich dafür sorgen
kann dass jedenfalls die geimpften stark
geschützt sind das nicht ungeimpfte aus
blankem egoismus und aus sturheit die
anderen in einer geiselhaft nehmen und
ein letzter satz verlor 1 habe ich im
verfassungsrecht gelernt auch artikel 2
absatz 2 die körperliche unversehrtheit
ist kein super grundrecht als
unantastbares nicht monat aussage ist
ein starkes grund die alten höchstwert
in der presse nicht
unanständig tierwohl verfassungsfest
machen können und wenn ich das urteil
das gericht zu den zur bundes notbremse
richtig sehe das zeigt dass sehr viel
spielraum da ist ich glaube nicht dass
ein verfassungsgericht das geändert
hätte oder aufgaben ein die hard punk
wir haben eine chance verpasst hier auf
die kohle die es den lehrgang verpassten
wir uns am anfang eine mehrheit gehabt
werden also bereit wir haben in ihrem
sie haben sich alle gruppen fachmann
nicht beteiligt haben sie im
gruppenweise freilich
streiten
also ein gutes bild die deutsche politik
nicht hinterlassen ein nicht die wellen
durch steht in flammen und wir können
uns nicht einmal auf eine schutzmaßnahme
wie sie auch ist einigen ich meine man
ich hätte erwartet ich war an zwei
kabinetten dass ein kabinett zunächst
einmal wirklich ernsthaft versucht eine
eigene meinung zu bilden und dann auch
die durchsetzt in der koalition muss
jeder mal nachgeben auch airbus man ne
aber herr bauen ist es nicht ist es
überhaupt noch eine frage der partei
oder nicht eher eine gewissensfrage
jedoch doch da können sie doch alles zur
gewissensfrage machen jeder bundesrat
gewissensfrage aber es geht würde ich
nicht immer mehr andere fragen wenn es
um sterbehilfe geht wenn es um
gentechnologie jedes jahr an zulagen
gewesen da geht es um einen
schwerwiegenden körperlichen eingriff in
die grundrechte und den kann man
durchaus als ethische frage sehen die
jeder kann sich selber bewerten muss und
das haben wir heute getan wir haben
heute eine debatte geführt die
sicherlich teilweise sehr lebhaft war
aber die auch genau das abgebildete was
auf den straßen in den gastwirtschaften
überall in unserer gesellschaft geführt
wird seit wochen wohnen naja da bekommen
wir unsere chance bekommen
hat für sie die leute die wir sind
dann ist es zu spät
nicht viele hätten die wenigsten die
vorbereitung machen können hier weil das
habe ich dem herrn gehören müsste die
impfzentren vorhalten über den sommer da
jetzt eigentlich das hat man einfach
vorgesehen hätten sie ja zustimmen
können
ist die auch bei der fdp bei kubicki
georgia bärchen und anderen vor
gekommene meinung wir brauchen das gar
nicht es gibt ganz andere mittel und
nicht die maske sondern anreize damit
kriegen wir zum impfen seit einem
dreiviertel jahr funktioniert das nicht
nein und der zweite punkt den ich noch
loswerden nur der erhalt der verweis auf
andere länder ist irreführend die haben
keine impfpflicht aber sie haben eine
impfquote vier teilweise 90 prozent für
ausgleichende länder wie spanien italien
wo wir immer sagen und immer den
sonderweg
nur sagen es liegen inzwischen auch
geimpfte es kaum leute auf den intensiv
stäglin das lieben viele andere aber es
ist nicht so dass die schweren verläufe
so extrem voll sind deswegen sind die
kliniken nicht voll ich muss ergänzen
wäre es um wer sich nicht impfen lassen
will hat dann das risiko dass er auch in
schweren verlauf hat und die ganzen
umgebung auch eben im moment omikron
weiter und deshalb ist dieses zwangs ich
bin für alle und dann ist das problem
gelöst so wie wir es im herbst viele
dachten dieses ist jetzt mit sony
konsolen nicht aber lassen sie mich noch
mal ergänzen in bremen sieht man ja an
der basis immunisierung was eine
zielgruppengerechte ansprache ich finde
wir haben noch nicht alles getan
bevölkerung gerade auch migrantische
hintergründe bevölkerung zum hintergrund
zu informieren in deren sprachen das
bringt jede menge haben noch jede menge
potenzial was herausholen kann und ich
glaube da haben wir nach unglückseligen
herr lauterbach nicht längst was
eingefangen das doch eure aufgabe ihre
gier dort ja seit drei monaten habe ich
aber hier bin habe ich echt schon einen
gedankengang reinbringen und zwar eben
auch schon drin hat ich möchte ihnen
nochmal auf nachhaken bei herr baum bei
der bremer die geimpften geben ist ja
auch weiter das ist dass sie mich so
sehr gegen die impfpflicht spricht also
inwiefern kann man den risikogruppen
schützen wenn man auch ansteckend ist
und den virus weiter gibt also das
spricht auch komplett gegen eine
impfpflicht also wir wissen doch dass
das weitergeben durch geimpfte oder auch
an geimpfte meist zu ganz milden
verläufen führt was wir verhindern
wollen ist doch im grunde dass wir
weiter eine mehrere millionen 14
millionen haben die ungeimpft durch die
gegend laufen und wenn sie infiziert
werden auf der intensivstation oder auf
dem totenbett land das kann man dadurch
verhindern dass man sie zu ihrem glück
ein wenig zwingt da muss ich
klar ebenso will meyer betreuungs
richterin das muss jetzt doch mal sagen
und leider leider da haben sie in
gewisser weise recht es wäre sinnvoll
sie zum glück vielleicht zu zwingen aber
das dürfen wir eben nicht
verfassungsrechtlich habe ich noch
brauchen um ein recht sogar marco zu
saufen es tut mir leid so drastisch zu
sagen jetzt haben inzwischen die
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts auch zur
sterbehilfe und sie wissen dass wir im
grunde faktisch jetzt auch ein recht zur
selbsttötung haben bilder kontrolle hat
johannes sagen das stimmt nicht wir
müssen die gegen ihren willen mit aller
macht zwingen es wäre es sinnvoll wenn
man sich weniger an steckt wenn das mal
weniger weitergibt das haben wir mit
omikron so nicht aber ich habe ein recht
die leute zu zwingen zum selbstschutz es
ist nicht mehr die frage ob man als
werden
lassen warum damals dachten wir auch ich
würde mich auch jetzt impfen lassen so
wenig ich würde auch mit rücksicht auf
meine beine tun es die virologen sagen
doch bei den ungeimpften entstehen die
mutation natürlich verlangt ich habe
gerne in ihre these dass jeder das recht
hat sich selbst zu schädigen sich selbst
geschädigt aber er hat nicht das recht
andere zu belästigen zu gefährden zudem
krank zu machen indem er seine infektion
weiter trägt das ist doch die frage ist
doch auch weiter aber da hatte ich die
gegend in europa aber warum dürfen wir
sehen folgen
hat sich verändert also ich für den
hobby sie haben sie heute die zeitung
gelesen es gibt in paris links über den
längst forschung wonach wir einen ganz
andere nämlich eine kombination von
delta und omikron zu erwarten habe
wunderbar museum haben haben wir haben
die haftpflicht also lassen wir das
wir lassen den 52 herr bremer